Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What is an assistant psychologist?
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。什么是助理心理学家？
What do they do and how should they be protected? With my guest, I am answering all of these questions and more for this really brilliant and insightful podcast episode. I hope you find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, as I have spoken about before, my route into professional psychology was via a series of assistant psychologist roles, but that is by no means the only way into professional psychology. However, it is still a really common one. So as part of this series, looking at assistant psychologists, I am bringing you a really brilliant, insightful,
他们做什么？他们应该如何受到保护？在这一期非常精彩且富有洞察力的播客中，我将与我的嘉宾一起回答所有这些问题以及更多内容。希望你会觉得这期节目很有用。欢迎收听《Aspiring Psychologist》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。正如我之前提到过的，我进入专业心理学领域的途径是通过一系列助理心理学家的职位，但这绝不是进入该领域的唯一途径。不过，这仍然是一个非常普遍的途径。因此，作为关注助理心理学家系列节目的一部分，我将为大家带来一场非常精彩、富有洞察力、
thoughtful, compassionate chat with my expert for today, Luke Meakin, who is himself an assistant psychologist. He is also an older applicant and so there are so many interesting areas for discussion. If you value this episode please do take a moment to like, subscribe, follow, comment if watching on YouTube or Spotify or just get in contact with me on socials or in my free Facebook group The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent. I hope you find it as interesting, as thought-provoking as I did. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Luke Meakin, who's an assistant psychologist. Welcome to the podcast, Luke.
体贴且充满同情心的对话，我的嘉宾是今天的专家Luke Meakin，他本人也是一名助理心理学家。他也是一位大龄申请者，所以我们有很多有趣的议题可以讨论。如果你觉得这期节目有价值，请花点时间点赞、订阅、关注，如果在YouTube或Spotify上观看，欢迎留言，或者通过社交媒体与我联系，也可以加入我的免费Facebook群组“The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent”。希望你觉得这期节目和我一样有趣且发人深省。期待在节目后与大家交流。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，助理心理学家Luke Meakin。欢迎来到播客，Luke。
Hi, Marianne. Thanks for having me on. Really appreciate it. Oh, well, thank you for being so curious, really. You know know so we got connected on LinkedIn exchange some kind of voice notes and messages and just thinking about you know what an assistant psychologist is what are the responsibilities and we thought it might make a really interesting podcast episode and certainly in preparation for this episode which I will hands up say I haven't had time to do full justice to which is probably probably part of the problem isn't it stuff we're going to talk about but I've just found it a really interesting process so thanks for kick-starting more of my thinking in this area already yeah that's that's fine it's good to have someone else to riff off because I
嗨，Marianne。谢谢邀请我来。非常感谢。哦，谢谢你的好奇心。你知道，我们在LinkedIn上建立了联系，交换了一些语音和信息，思考着“什么是助理心理学家，职责是什么”，我们觉得这可能会成为一期非常有趣的播客。当然，在准备这期节目时——我得承认我没有时间做到尽善尽美，这可能也是问题的一部分，对吧？我们待会儿会谈到——但我发现这是一个非常有趣的过程，所以感谢你激发了我对这个领域更多的思考。是的，这很好，有个人可以交流是很棒的，因为我
myself spend a lot of time wondering what an assistant psychologist does and is even though I've been in it for two years now. Yeah and having been an assistant I found it really interesting so we're kind of referring within today to the guidance put together by the Association for Clinical Psychologists. And in case anyone hasn't heard of them before, they are not our professional body as clinical psychologists. You can join it as a qualified clinical psychologist or as a trainee clinical psychologist. I think it would be really lovely if they thought about opening that up to people in earlier stages of their career, but it isn't currently. So in the UK, our professional body for clinical psychology is the Healthcare Professions Council, HCPC, and that's who we pay our registration to. And again, you can't join as an assistant psychologist it's only for practitioner
自己也花了很多时间思考助理心理学家到底是做什么的，尽管我已经在这个岗位上工作了两年了。是的，作为一名助理，我发现这非常有趣。所以我们今天会参考临床心理学家协会（ACP）制定的指南。如果有人没听说过他们，他们不是我们临床心理学家的专业机构。你可以以合格的临床心理学家或临床心理学实习生的身份加入。如果他们能考虑向职业生涯早期的人开放，那会非常棒，但目前还没有。在英国，我们的临床心理学专业机构是健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC），我们向他们缴纳注册费。同样，你不能以助理心理学家的身份加入，它只针对执业
psychologists of which there are currently nine in the uk i think i'm right in saying so yes in case you've landed on this podcast and you're like what is this um you know what is an assistant psychologist what's your understanding of what an assistant psychologist is Luke if that's not too big a question to dump on you um I suppose it can be quite broad my my my big issue is the ambiguity of the role and I think that's why I reached out to you however my understanding I suppose would begin with um the work that the psychologist the the qualified psychologist can give up and give someone else. And, you know, for want of a better term, potentially the grunt work of the profession. That's how I used to think of it anyway. And that would be, you know, extra research, some psychometric testing, probably say note-taking, letters, these sorts of things.
心理学家，我想我没记错的话，英国目前有九位。所以，如果你刚点进这个播客，心想“这是什么？嗯，什么是助理心理学家？”，Luke，如果这个问题太大，你觉得助理心理学家是什么？嗯，我想这个角色可能非常广泛。我最大的困扰是这个角色的模糊性，我想这也是我联系你的原因。不过，我的理解是从合格心理学家可以放弃并交给别人做的工作开始。而且，用一个不太好听的词来说，可能是这个职业的“苦差事”。我以前就是这么想的。比如额外的研究、一些心理测量测试、记笔记、写信等等。
At least that's what I used to think. And then when getting into the profession, I have had multiple, maybe conflicting experiences. And then talking to others, some have had much more pressure on them, essentially kind of doing half of the psychologist's work you know quite a lot of quite a lot of clinical facing work with clients that maybe have too much risk for them because I suppose I would expect an assistant to have clinical facing work but be very very managed and maintained in that work so I suppose my original understanding was just the extra bits that the psychologist can afford to get rid of. Yeah, exactly. And I guess I've always
至少我以前是这么想的。后来进入这个行业后，我有过多种、有时甚至是相互矛盾的经历。和别人交流后，我发现有些人承受的压力要大得多，基本上是在做心理学家一半的工作，你知道，有很多面对客户的临床工作，而这些工作对他们来说风险可能太大了。因为我想我会期望助理有面对客户的工作，但这些工作应该受到非常严格的管理和维护。所以我想我最初的理解只是心理学家可以腾出手的额外琐事。是的，没错。而且我一直
thought about it as allowing the full and optimal functioning and capabilities of a qualified clinical or forensic or you know occupational psychologist whilst optimizing their function without them having to do some of the stuff that doesn't necessarily need to be done by a qualified psychologist that could be done under supervision of a practitioner psychologist. And let's not make this purely about clinical, but a practitioner HCP psychologist. So for example, it's important that we make that distinction, because actually, I was an assistant clinical psychologist in a forensic service. And primarily in my first service, I was supervised by a clinical psychologist. But in my second assistant post, still with me, I was supervised by a forensic psychologist and actually really valued the supervision from both of those practitioner psychologists. But it was very clear that I was working towards a clinical doctorate route.
认为，这能让合格的临床、法医或职业心理学家发挥最佳功能和能力，同时优化他们的工作，让他们不必做那些不一定非要由合格心理学家完成、可以在执业心理学家监督下完成的事情。我们不要只谈临床，而是谈HCPC执业心理学家。例如，做出这种区分很重要，因为实际上，我曾在法医服务部门担任助理临床心理学家。在第一个服务岗位上，我主要由一位临床心理学家监督。但在第二个助理岗位上，我仍然和我在一起，我由一位法医心理学家监督，我确实非常重视这两位执业心理学家的监督。但很明显，我是在朝着临床博士学位的方向努力。
But the supervision should feel valued it should feel appropriate it should feel like it allows you to thrive as as a junior member of the psychology team and i know before we hit record both of us were quite intrigued by the the guidance that we read by ACP that said, actually, the stuff in between your psychology graduation and your getting on to professional doctorate is not a training role. Why did that resonate with you, Luke? I know why it resonated with me, but why did that resonate with you so much? I suppose it was really strange to see it written down because logically it makes sense, I suppose. But we are picking up so much extra experience in these roles that is psychologically
但监督应该让人感到被重视，应该感到合适，应该让你作为心理学团队的初级成员茁壮成长。我知道在录音前，我们俩都对ACP的指南感到非常好奇，指南说，心理学毕业到进入专业博士课程之间的阶段并不是一个“培训角色”。Luke，为什么这引起了你的共鸣？我知道它为什么引起我的共鸣，但为什么它对你影响这么大？我想是因为看到它被写下来真的很奇怪，因为从逻辑上讲，这是说得通的。但我们在这些角色中确实积累了太多额外的经验，这些经验是心理学
informed, whether it is direct or indirect and by direct i mean you know through supervision and so on indirect the things you pick up maybe your own reflection um reflective practice but i suppose it was really poignant to me because there is i'm trying to get on the doctorate myself there is such such a a bloodbath when it comes to applications and how difficult that period is and everyone's sort of competing against each other. We have these tons and tons of experience between many of us that on paper, I suppose technically isn't counted, which seems like it's counterproductive for the profession because psychology is supposed to be able to take a bird's eye view above everything and sort of ask why, what else. And the only way you can keep asking why is if you have professionals that have different experiences, I think,
相关的，无论是直接的（通过监督等）还是间接的（比如你自己的反思、反思性实践）。但我认为它对我来说非常深刻，因为我正在努力申请博士学位，申请过程简直是一场“血战”，这段时期非常艰难，每个人都在互相竞争。我们很多人之间积累了大量的经验，但在纸面上，我想技术上是不被计算的，这似乎对这个行业适得其反。因为心理学应该能够从全局俯瞰一切，并询问“为什么，还有什么”。而你保持追问“为什么”的唯一方法，就是拥有具有不同经验的专业人士，我认为，
because everyone should have the fundamental foundational knowledge which the training would dictate, and then your own experience should be able to take that in different ways and potentially like a creative avenue. So it was surprising to see it written down, I suppose, because it seems like a disconnect with the application process. For clinical and forensic, I have some friends who are on the forensic route as well. It seems quite similar in that sense.
因为每个人都应该拥有培训所要求的根本基础知识，然后你自己的经验应该能够以不同的方式吸收这些知识，并可能开辟一条创造性的途径。所以看到它被写下来很令人惊讶，因为它似乎与申请过程脱节了。对于临床和法医方向，我有一些朋友也在走法医路线。在这个意义上，情况似乎非常相似。
So what are we to do with this experience that we're told to be reflective of and take supervision with? It's quite strange to me, quite conflicting. Yeah, and I hope it didn't feel like a kick in the teeth that kind of said you don't matter like it's I didn't necessarily read it that way and all the stuff you're doing it's just pointless like it doesn't matter I almost took it as you don't hold clinical responsibility you know you don't even hold that as a trainee um you know I signed for the first time as a qualified psychologist in my new band seven post and I think there needs to be more done to help you really begin to think about that clinical responsibility but that's a whole different podcast episode that's a really good point yeah I suppose you are right it should be used as sort of no this is the sort of thing I need to be doing I need to
那么，我们该如何处理这些被告知要进行反思并接受监督的经验呢？对我来说这很奇怪，很矛盾。是的，我希望这不会让你觉得像是一种打击，好像在说“你无关紧要”，或者“你所做的一切都是毫无意义的，这并不重要”。我几乎把它理解为“你不承担临床责任”，你知道，即使是实习生也不承担。我第一次以合格心理学家的身份在新的七级岗位上签字时，我想需要做更多的工作来帮助你真正开始思考那种临床责任，但这又是另一个播客话题了。这是一个很好的观点。是的，我想你是对的，它应该被用作一种“这正是我需要做的事情，我需要
be training I need to be doing xyz I didn't think of it as a kick in the teeth. I kind of see it as once I am qualified, all my experience will be really helpful. And it's already helpful in my life now. But it's just strange to see in that format. But you make a really great point. It should be used more of a shield for us. It should feel so safe.
进行培训，我需要做XYZ”的指引。我并没有把它看作是一种打击。我把它看作是，一旦我获得资格，我所有的经验都会非常有帮助。而且它现在在我的生活中已经很有帮助了。只是以这种格式看到它很奇怪。但你提出了一个很好的观点。它应该更多地被用作我们的盾牌。它应该让人感到非常安全。
It should feel like an opportunity to grow learn develop reflect be curious have fun as well you know you should be having fun within your psychology teams it should hopefully feel like a safe place where you can be yourself and you can be valued as being yourself. And I have to say that my experience of being an assistant in both of my assistant settings. So I did do a split post across three wards when I was in my first assistant post, which was very varied and very diverse. But then my second one was um just in one setting with youth offending population but both times i felt really valued by the teams um and i was invited on you know socials and stuff with the teams um both the psychology teams and the ward teams and
它应该让人感到这是一个成长、学习、发展、反思、保持好奇心和享受乐趣的机会。你知道，你在心理学团队中应该感到快乐。它应该是一个安全的地方，你可以做你自己，并因为做你自己而受到重视。我必须说，我在两个助理岗位上的经历都很好。我在第一个助理岗位时，跨越了三个病房，工作非常多样化。但第二个岗位是在一个专门针对青少年犯罪的机构。但两次我都感到团队非常重视我，我被邀请参加团队的社交活动，无论是心理学团队还是病房团队。
it was it's really nice to feel you know I put a post out on my LinkedIn yesterday about the trainee room or the assistant room and people being introduced at meetings as this is my assistant this is my trainee actually no this is Luke and he works with us and as an assistant psychologist in the team it's so different and actually it's sick organizations that think about people maybe it's burned out clinicians that think about people as as replaceable as interchangeable when actually I should be if you're my assistant you know even as my podcast guest I'm curious I'm thinking how can we help Luke to shape to be developed to learn to grow to to think about this as an opportunity for dissemination for his
感觉真好。我昨天在LinkedIn上发了一篇关于“实习生室”或“助理室”的帖子，提到人们在会议上被介绍为“这是我的助理，这是我的实习生”。其实不，这是Luke，他与我们一起工作。作为团队中的助理心理学家，这太不同了。实际上，那些把人看作是可替换、可互换的（可能是因为倦怠的临床医生）组织，其实是病态的。如果我是你的助理，即使作为我的播客嘉宾，我也会好奇，我在想：我们如何帮助Luke塑造、发展、学习、成长，如何让他把这看作是一个为他
his future career you know for hopefully something that that is useful for him as well as useful for the listeners and useful for me as a podcast host you you know, and I think you'd be, you know, even that we're having these curious existential professional qualifications, you know, it's all a bit Dawson's Creek, isn't it? That's probably a very 90s reference. But I think you've obviously a great assistant psychologist, you've got great capabilities for doing this highly nuanced work that we do. Thank you for that. The Dawson's Cleat reference didn't go over my head. I'm a little bit older than your average AP.
未来职业生涯传播的机会？你知道，希望这对他也很有用，对听众有用，对我这个播客主持人也有用。你知道，我们正在进行这些关于专业资格的好奇的、存在主义的讨论，这有点像《恋爱时代》（Dawson's Creek），不是吗？那可能是一个非常90年代的梗。但我认为你显然是一位出色的助理心理学家，你有能力从事我们所做的这种高度细致的工作。谢谢你。那个《恋爱时代》的梗我听懂了。我比一般的助理心理学家稍微大一点。
So, no, thank you for that. I think what you were just saying reminded me of why I sort of, or the question that I reached out to you with, which wasn't necessarily a question, but wondering about the ambiguity of the role that I personally struggle with at times. So I've come from, throughout my twenties, I worked in various different industries. I had the undergraduate and then a kind of, and a master's and I veered off and did a few other things. And I suppose that there was a lot of structure in those roles very different industries some were construction marketing and so on um but there was a lot of
所以，不，谢谢你。我想你刚才说的让我想起了我为什么会提出那个问题，或者说我联系你时提出的问题。那不一定是一个问题，而是对这个角色模糊性的困惑，我有时会为此挣扎。我二十多岁时在各种不同的行业工作过。我有本科学位，然后还有硕士学位，但我中途转向做了一些其他事情。我想在那些角色中有很多结构，尽管行业非常不同，有些是建筑、市场营销等等，但有很多
structure that allowed for creativity because most of the end game was numbers you know you had to produce numbers you had to produce sales and and it was easy in that sense. Whereas I suppose coming into psychology, I mean my second assistant post now and I did some work as a healthcare assistant prior to that, I found that the written structure is there. So on your job application, your job spec and so forth, there is less creativity probably because you are working with individuals of risk, for sure. But there seems to be a barrier with assistance, with where we can be creative in our work sometimes. Because I think some people expect us to be able to be like a mini psychologist and be doing much more client work. And then I'd probably say in the experience of my own experience
结构允许创造力，因为大多数最终目标是数字，你知道，你必须产生数字，你必须产生销售额，从这个意义上说，这很容易。而进入心理学领域，我现在是第二个助理岗位，在此之前我还做过医疗助理，我发现书面结构是存在的。在你的工作申请、职位描述等中，创造力可能较少，因为你确实是在与有风险的个人一起工作。但助理在某些方面似乎存在创造力的障碍。因为我认为有些人期望我们能像“迷你心理学家”一样，做更多客户工作。然后我可能会说，根据我与
of other people who I've worked with, they may be the ones who are not the psychologists themselves. I think the psychologists tend to be quite aware of what we should and shouldn't be doing because, like yourself, they've all been through it, which is really good. There just might not be enough of them around because of pressures pressures as you've alluded to there might be another podcast episode but i suppose to bring it back the ambiguity i struggle with is there can be such variance across posts one post can be very research admin based one can be very clinical facing and no
我共事过的其他人的经验，他们可能不是心理学家本人。我认为心理学家往往非常清楚我们应该和不应该做什么，因为像你一样，他们都经历过，这非常好。只是因为压力，可能没有足够的心理学家在场，正如你所提到的，这可能是另一个播客话题。但我想回到那个模糊性，我挣扎的是，不同岗位之间的差异太大了。一个岗位可能非常偏向研究和行政，另一个可能非常偏向临床，而没有
research admin based and from the document that we both just read prior to this it seems the former the research and admin based stuff is what an assistant should technically be doing or what it was set up for originally and that really struck me because to me that experience like the anomaly when into it, my perception was that the research in acne was kind of the anomaly side of things. It was extra skills an assistant can pick up for later on, and it should be more clinical facing, whereas in actual fact, it shouldn't be. Yeah, I thought it was really interesting. The document kind of spoke about the historical beginnings
研究和行政工作。根据我们刚才读的文件，似乎前者（研究和行政）才是助理在技术上应该做的，或者说是最初设立这个职位的初衷。这让我很震惊，因为对我来说，那种经验就像是一个异常情况。我的感知是，研究和行政工作是异常的一面。那是助理以后可以掌握的额外技能，它应该更多地偏向临床，而实际上，它不应该。是的，我觉得这很有趣。这份文件谈到了助理心理学家角色的历史起源，
of the assistant psychologist role which was originally called something else which escapes me i think it was a psychology technician i think yeah that rings a bell um but it was originally put together as a role for kind of inpatient services so that it could support the optimal functioning so that things that didn't need to necessarily be done by the qualified could be done by a graduate psychology person. You know, so someone with a psychology undergraduate degree that knew about, I guess, knew about the principles of clinical significance. significance and you know if they were doing assessments or neuropsych that was appropriate to the role that they knew about you know important effects to do and not do and kind of mindful considerations and could act under supervision without too much kind of ad lib or
它最初叫别的名字，我忘了，我想是“心理学技术员”，我想是的，听起来很耳熟。但它最初是作为一种为住院服务提供的角色，这样它就可以支持最佳功能，让那些不一定非要由合格人员完成的事情可以由心理学毕业生来完成。你知道，就是一个拥有心理学本科学位、了解临床意义原则的人。如果他们在做评估或神经心理学，那对角色来说是合适的，他们知道重要的影响，知道该做什么和不该做什么，并且可以在监督下行动，而不会有太多的即兴发挥或
changing what was going on but that was why they were created and I guess even in my role now you know stuff that I have to do with the background stuff for the psychology podcast it's really admin heavy it's really boring um at times I have to say um you know this is a labor of love people so please please do be kind takes me hours and hours and hours of my week which is unpaid time um but sometimes I get people you know contacting me saying could I do some um assistant psychologist or honorary psychology work and because I'm online only with my clinical practice these days there's not really anything they can do that's clinical. So it doesn't feel like a fair use of their time to just come and do my boring admin. And I also believe in people being paid for their time as well.
改变正在进行的事情。但这就是他们被创造的原因。我想即使在我现在的角色中，我为心理学播客做的背景工作，行政负担真的很重，真的很无聊。有时我不得不说，你知道，这是爱的劳动，大家请一定要善待我。这每周要花掉我好几个小时，而且是无偿的时间。但有时有人联系我，问我是否可以做一些助理心理学家或荣誉心理学工作。因为我现在的临床实践只在线上，所以他们真的没有什么临床工作可做。所以让他们来做我无聊的行政工作，感觉并不是对他们时间的公平利用。而且我也相信人们应该为自己的时间获得报酬。
So I don't believe in honorary assistant posts. And there's a whole podcast episode hopefully my lovely podcast editor will put on screen now about kind of the ethical and practical considerations involved and inherent in honorary assistant psychologist roles but um yeah it's interesting that in the guidance in the document that we read really it's recommending that kind of 50 percent of an assistant psychologist time ought to be admin, but it's ought to be relevant admin that needs to be done by someone with psychology training, psychology education, I should say. It shouldn't just be photocopying. And I know that sometimes I've worked with people who have kind of felt like they've been duped into applying for an admin assistant role at perhaps band three, band four, maybe even band five, that maybe they couldn't fill before. And it's been rebranded as assistant psychologist.
所以我不支持荣誉助理职位。希望我可爱的播客编辑现在能在屏幕上放出一期关于荣誉助理心理学家职位所涉及的道德和实践考虑的播客。但确实，我们读到的指南中很有趣的一点是，它建议助理心理学家50%的时间应该是行政工作，但那应该是需要具备心理学培训、心理学教育背景的人才能完成的相关行政工作。不应该只是复印。我知道有时我共事过的人觉得他们被骗去申请了一个三级、四级甚至五级的行政助理职位，可能是因为他们之前招不到人。然后它被重新包装成“助理心理学家”。
Suddenly, they've got hundreds of applicants for this role but when it comes about it's it's all admin and no psychology and very little supervision from a practitioner psychologist and it all just feels like a horrid scam yeah i i definitely agree with the it sounds like a horrid scam it feels like a horrid scam to to many people because where are you supposed to be picking up the experience of what a first trainee and then a clinical psychologist would be doing because I think it's really important if you're if an AP is lucky enough to be in a service that has a trainee as well because they can sort of gauge the next step on regardless of whether it's clinical forensic they can gauge the next step because I've heard of some people having supervision from like very very senior positions in their team and there's probably quite a wide disconnect between the assistant and the
突然间，他们收到了数百份申请，但当真正入职时，全是行政工作，没有心理学内容，而且几乎没有执业心理学家的监督，这感觉就像一场可怕的骗局。是的，我绝对同意，这听起来像一场可怕的骗局，对许多人来说，这感觉就像一场可怕的骗局。因为你本应该在哪里积累实习生和临床心理学家所做的工作经验呢？我认为如果助理心理学家有幸在也有实习生的服务部门工作，那是非常重要的，因为他们可以衡量下一步，无论临床还是法医，他们都可以衡量下一步。因为我听说有些人接受团队中非常资深职位的监督，而助理与
senior whether it's responsibility or time away from being an assistant because it's been 10-15 years since they've been one um so the the scam thing sounds right and it's it's wrong that that's what we're dealing with at times but i must go back to your original point that you made about spending all your time doing research for the for the podcast i think speak for myself and many others um it's very important for the community. So thank you for that time of putting into research. We all benefit from it. Oh, thanks, Luke.
资深人员之间可能存在很大的脱节，无论是责任还是因为他们已经有10-15年没做过助理了。所以“骗局”这个说法是对的，我们有时要面对这种情况是错误的。但我必须回到你最初提到的关于花所有时间为播客做研究的观点。我想代表我自己和许多其他人说，这对社区非常重要。所以感谢你投入时间进行研究。我们都从中受益。哦，谢谢你，Luke。
That's really kind of you to say. Like, I love this podcast. Like, I love it. Like, I feel, I get all misty-eyed, but I feel so proud of it. Like, I would have loved to listen to this and to just be open to these experiences when I was an assistant psychologist. So I was part of, so my first assistant post, it was in a large psychiatric hospital, St. Andrew's Hospital, St. Andrew's Healthcare, I should say, in Northampton. And there was absolutely loads of assistants. And so we'd have assistant meetings and do presentations. But for me, I found there's a real value of
你这么说真是太好了。我喜欢这个播客。我真的喜欢它。我感到热泪盈眶，但我为它感到非常自豪。如果我在做助理心理学家时能听到这些，并对这些经历保持开放态度，那该多好。所以，我第一个助理岗位是在北安普顿的一家大型精神病院，St. Andrew's Healthcare。那里有大量的助理。所以我们会举行助理会议并进行演讲。但对我来说，我发现
listening to people at a similar stage of your career. But like you said, being able to think, well, actually, that was an interview with a trainee. And I used to love going to ward meetings, for example, when a trainee was presenting or present and hearing them formulate or hearing the way that they spoke about clients and clinical work so that I could see, you know, where I perhaps needed to be aiming for and where the gaps in my experience were. And like you said, if I'm only ever working with 8B or 8C psychologists, I might feel like I'm coming up short all the time. But actually, what we also need to be aware of is that you may be an absolute whiz at neuropsych and psychosis populations. I may never have done any of that. And yet we might still be similarly ready and brilliant for clinical training and I think that's something that was spoken about in an episode I did with Alistair Teague and one of his wonderful assistant psychologists
倾听处于职业生涯相似阶段的人的经历非常有价值。但就像你说的，能够思考“嗯，那是一次与实习生的面试”。我以前很喜欢参加病房会议，例如，当实习生在场或演讲时，听他们如何进行案例构思，或者听他们谈论客户和临床工作的方式，这样我就可以看到我可能需要瞄准的目标，以及我经验中的差距在哪里。就像你说的，如果我只和8B或8C级的心理学家一起工作，我可能会一直觉得自己做得不够。但实际上，我们也需要意识到，你可能在神经心理学和精神病学人群方面是个绝对的专家。我可能从未做过任何这些。然而，我们可能同样准备好并出色地进入临床培训。我认为我在之前与Alistair Teague和他的一位出色的助理心理学家做的节目中谈到过这一点，
a little while back and that was called how to get an assistant psychologist post but Alistair was like I don't want to know all the stuff you've done I want to look at what your abilities are like I said like your ability to be able to be curious to learn to be reflective to to be a really wonderful assistant psychologist without necessarily you know you don't need to have this identikit experience, because actually, when you do join any professional doctorate, you know, whether that is forensic, whether that is clinical, whether that's counselling, I would like to look at that cohort and feel that probably across all of the cohort, there's all of the key bits that have been met but they're not what no one person has all of
那期节目叫《如何获得助理心理学家职位》。但Alistair说：“我不想知道你做过的所有事情，我想看看你的能力是什么。”就像我说的，比如你保持好奇、学习、反思的能力，成为一名非常出色的助理心理学家，而不一定非要拥有这种“模版化”的经验。因为实际上，当你加入任何专业博士课程时，无论是法医、临床还是咨询，我都希望看到那个群体，并感觉到可能在整个群体中，所有的关键点都得到了满足，但没有人从培训一开始就拥有所有这些，
that already at the beginning of training otherwise they wouldn't be needing training would they um that you kind of complement each other and so myself and one of my peers were the only people that had had any forensic experience so if there was issues around risk and forensic, we'd be a natural first checking point. But people who, you know, we had a qualified teacher on our cohort. So issues around, you know, around education and the school setting. Naturally, he was someone that we would kind of draw on and people that were parents on the cohort and people that had worked in people with intellectual in services for people with intellectual disabilities you know this is this is the beauty of a cohort and seeing each other not as competition which I know is really
否则他们就不需要培训了，对吧？你们是互补的。所以我和我的一位同伴是群体中唯一有法医经验的人。所以如果出现关于风险和法医的问题，我们就是自然的第一个咨询点。但我们群体中有一位合格的教师。所以关于教育和学校环境的问题，他自然就是我们求助的对象。还有群体中的父母，以及在智力障碍服务部门工作过的人。你知道，这就是群体的美妙之处，把彼此看作伙伴而不是竞争对手。我知道当你争取名额时这真的
really tricky when you are striving for places but I used to go to those assistant meetings and to begin with I was like well I'm never going to get on training because um you know Vicky I'm going to name her Vicky who is on LinkedIn um who is amazing um she's got a book as well about happiness and kind of psychology and positive psychology Dr Vicky Barnes I hope it's okay to name you Vicky I remember watching you watching her present on kind of dbt stuff and I was like well I said I'm never I'm never gonna get to be a trainee because Vicky and other people like Vicky are much better than me and they are gonna get all the places and I'm not good enough, you know. But actually, we ended up getting onto training exactly the same year, different universities, but then we applied to different universities, you know. And it's really thinking about the people that you're working with,
很难，但我以前去参加那些助理会议时，起初我想：“我永远也进不了培训，因为……Vicky（我要点名Vicky，她在LinkedIn上，她很棒），她还有一本关于幸福和积极心理学的书，Vicky Barnes博士，希望点名你没关系，Vicky。”我记得看着她展示关于DBT的内容，我想：“好吧，我永远也成不了实习生，因为Vicky和像Vicky这样的人比我好得多，他们会得到所有的名额，而我不够好。”但实际上，我们最终在同一年进入了培训，虽然是不同的大学，但我们申请了不同的大学。所以，这真的是要思考与你共事的人，
as people, so the way I'd moved by the time we both got in training, moved to really celebrate others and to try and champion other assistants and other people kind of in upcoming. This is still what I do now, rather than necessarily being threatened. You know, what do we get when we build other people up rather than be threatened by them and actually jealousy is a really important concept in itself because jealousy is often seeing someone who's got what you want and rather than saying oh my god amazing well done we can be wanting to tear people down but that's our jealousy which is a very complicated emotion but I think it is I think it does come up in psychology yeah i think you make a great point um that we shouldn't be trying to tear each other down because as you earlier said no one has all the the skills and the experience and we'd hope that again everyone's everyone starts at some sort of baseline foundational skill that they're allowed to practice in the future
把他们当作人来看待。所以到我们都进入培训时，我已经转变为真正庆祝他人的成就，并试图支持其他助理和其他即将进入这个领域的人。我现在依然这样做，而不是感到被威胁。你知道，当我们建立他人而不是被他们威胁时，我们会得到什么？实际上，嫉妒本身就是一个非常重要的概念，因为嫉妒往往是看到别人拥有你想要的东西，而不是说“天哪，太棒了，做得好”。我们可能会想要诋毁别人，但那是我们的嫉妒，这是一种非常复杂的情绪。但我认为它确实出现在心理学领域。是的，我认为你提出了一个很好的观点，我们不应该试图诋毁彼此，因为正如你之前所说，没有人拥有所有的技能和经验。我们希望每个人都从某种基准基础技能开始，并被允许在未来进行实践，
for safety reasons and risk and just keeping everything sort of the same across the board. But then celebrating the backgrounds, the different experiences, whether that is particular posts you've worked in, like you mentioned the forensic work, would really help you with risk and probably also being less risk averse as well because you in certain certain environments you've seen the worst of it the most risky so we can probably try this we can try that where someone without that background may think that the risk they're dealing with is the maximum.
出于安全和风险原因，并保持各方面的统一。但随后要庆祝背景和不同的经验，无论是你工作过的特定岗位，比如你提到的法医工作，这确实会帮助你处理风险，也可能让你不那么“风险厌恶”，因为在某些环境中，你见过最糟糕、风险最高的情况。所以我们可能会想“我们可以尝试这个，我们可以尝试那个”，而没有这种背景的人可能会认为他们正在处理的风险就是最大的风险。
And your story about Vicky kind of resonated with me, but from a different point of view. So when I was working with, when I was lucky enough to have trainees in our service as well, that was kind of the moment for me where I said, oh, I can probably do this. Because I didn't see them too far away from me because we'd had talks, we'd had discussions, and I was quite surprised that I was almost on a level with them about what we were discussing about. And they didn't feel like they were too far away from me in development perspective, which prior to meeting them, I kind of thought, this mysterious doctorate route, they must be, they must be really hot shots in their own profession.
你关于Vicky的故事引起了我的共鸣，但从不同的角度来看。当我幸运地在我们的服务部门也有实习生时，那对我来说是一个时刻，我说：“哦，我可能也能做到这一点。”因为我觉得他们离我不远，因为我们进行过交谈和讨论，我很惊讶我几乎和他们在讨论的内容上处于同一水平。从发展的角度来看，他们并不觉得离我太远。在见到他们之前，我以为这个神秘的博士路线，他们一定是自己行业里的“大人物”。
And they had their own limitations and they were able to call them out and we were able to adapt and work together. And I think since then, and possibly because I'm a bit like, I'm in my early thirties now, which is not typical for your APs. I've kind of had, I've kind of had to continue to remind myself, what else do you bring? Like I have academics behind me and I have the experience that I need.
他们有自己的局限性，他们能够指出来，我们能够适应并一起工作。从那以后，可能因为我现在三十出头，这对于助理心理学家来说并不典型，我不得不继续提醒自己：“你还带来了什么？”我有学术背景，我有我需要的经验。
What else do I bring to the table? Because instead of looking at it like a competition, it's like, what else can I naturally bring out of others? Because I have my own skills in a team, social and technical. But then as you said, other people have those skills. And how do you mesh them together and create the service that you need? Because I've also been supervised by very senior people. And I've learned so much from them in how to sort of manage, how they manage services, how they run services.
我还能带来什么？因为与其把它看作一场竞争，不如看作是：我还能自然地从别人身上挖掘出什么？因为我在团队中拥有自己的社交和技术技能。但正如你所说，其他人也有这些技能。你如何将它们融合在一起，创造出你需要的服务？因为我也曾受到非常资深人士的监督。我从他们身上学到了很多关于如何管理、如何运营服务的知识。
Not that I'll need that skill now, but just how to deal with people, conflicting points of view in the MDT and how to sit back and sort of let people speak, which clinicians definitely need. We definitely need to be able to listen. How to deal with conflicting sort of opinions and make people feel empowered. So that's not necessarily a skill that I'm going to need in my client-facing stuff as much in the immediate future, long-term maybe, after training and such. But it's really valuable to have the contrasting sort of experiences from very senior and people just ahead of me so it was it was definitely good to be able to work with
虽然我现在可能不需要那种技能，但只是关于如何与人打交道、如何处理多学科团队（MDT）中相互冲突的观点，以及如何退后一步让别人发言，这些都是临床医生绝对需要的。我们绝对需要能够倾听。如何处理相互冲突的意见并让人们感到被赋权。所以这不一定是我在不久的将来在面对客户的工作中需要用到的技能，长期来看可能需要，在培训之后。但拥有来自非常资深的人和刚刚领先于我的人的对比经验是非常宝贵的。所以能够与
the different professions and see what we can all bring different levels of the profession as opposed to seeing it as competition absolutely and you make so many wonderful points like yeah we should be we should be in roles where we're being allowed to grow and develop and where we are I guess having those regular check-in points you know more regularly than our um our appraisals people should be having appraisals every year where we're actually looking at ksfs you know so if I'm currently a four, what do I need to be doing to be moving towards the responsibilities of a band five member of staff? So you're actually looking ahead at what the KSFs are for band five. And your employer, I get quite often people are like, oh,
不同的专业人士共事，看看我们所有人能在职业生涯的不同阶段带来什么，而不是把它看作竞争，这绝对是件好事。你提出了很多精彩的观点，是的，我们应该处于被允许成长和发展的角色中，我们应该有那些定期的检查点，比我们的年度评估更频繁。人们应该每年进行评估，我们实际上是在查看知识与技能框架（KSF）。所以如果我现在是四级，我需要做什么才能向五级员工的职责迈进？所以你实际上是在展望五级的KSF。而你的雇主……我经常听到人们说：“哦，
they're going to be annoyed when I hand my notice in are they going to be disappointed that I've only been in this role for six months and now I'm on clinical training and I was like they should be delighted they should be thrilled that you are developing that what you are doing in your service has helped you to advance you know I know it is a bit of a headache re-recruiting because it's an expensive, laborious process. But they picked you because you are so amazing and you've demonstrated how amazing you are because you're now moving on to the next stage of your career. So I really hope people are met with celebration rather than dismay when they share their happy news. But you also made a really valid point about me and my forensic roles. I actually did need to spend time
当我递交辞呈时，他们会感到恼火吗？他们会因为我只在这个岗位上工作了六个月，现在就要去参加临床培训而感到失望吗？”我说：“他们应该感到高兴，他们应该为你正在发展而感到激动。你在服务部门所做的事情帮助你取得了进步。”我知道重新招聘确实有点头疼，因为这是一个昂贵且费力的过程。但他们选择你是因为你太棒了，而且你已经证明了你有多棒，因为你现在正在进入职业生涯的下一个阶段。所以我真的希望人们在分享喜讯时，得到的是庆祝而不是沮丧。但你也提到了关于我和我的法医角色的一个非常有效的观点。我确实需要在临床培训期间花时间，
during my clinical training, unlearning some of that risk for normal populations. You know, so we always need to be thinking with a risk element to some extent. But the level of risk that I was used to working with, which is where someone might stab you in the eye with a pen at any point, you know, or that you might open a bedroom door, and even an older adult would be crouched in the corner of the room ready to pounce, you know. So that is not hugely typical in, for example, a general mental health setting, but it's not impossible. You know, I'm always careful. I was always careful with my positioning of my chairs in the clinical rooms and stuff, because just makes sense but there are certain levels of sitting
“卸载”一些针对普通人群的风险意识。你知道，所以我们总是需要在某种程度上带着风险因素进行思考。但我习惯处理的风险水平是，有人可能随时用笔刺伤你的眼睛，或者你可能会打开卧室门，即使是一位老年人也会蹲在房间角落准备扑过来。你知道，这在一般心理健康环境中并不常见，但并非不可能。你知道，我总是很小心，我总是很小心我在临床室里椅子的摆放位置等等，因为这很有道理。但确实存在某些坐姿的水平。
with risk that you need to begin to be able to do in non-forensic services so that's a really really good point it might have been that the the trainee i felt like i was i was able to go into training or i felt like i was more ready since meeting them because they were they were so close um as opposed to initially thinking they are these hot shots that are way ahead of me i thought there's a few things which kind of alludes to your point like what should we be working towards yeah if you can see it you can be it can't you whereas if you're only ever seeing you know the a b c's d's you might be like well i don't know where the next stage is you know and yeah really really lovely stuff and let's have a think then about what assistants should be doing according to the
你需要开始在非司法服务中承担风险，这是一个非常好的观点。可能是我觉得作为实习生，我能够进入培训，或者自从见到他们后，我觉得自己准备得更充分了，因为他们离我很近，而不是最初认为他们是遥不可及的高手。我想有几件事，正如你所指出的，我们应该朝着什么目标努力？是的，如果你能看到它，你就能成为它，对吧？而如果你只看到ABC，你可能不知道下一个阶段在哪里。非常棒的内容，让我们来思考一下助理心理学家应该根据ACP指南做什么。
ACP guidance so examples of responsibilities that may be delegated and I think that's an important word in itself can include dependent on experience and training manualized group interventions, manualised one-to-one interventions, psychometric assessments, completing and inputting data under supervision. That doesn't mean like someone sitting under your, over your shoulder, just means it should be reviewed under supervision. Semi-structured history taking assessments, lit reviews and research, including audit and service evaluation, making and modifying resources approved by supervisor, teamwork, reflective practice, engaging in, not facilitating team meetings, networking, peer supervision and training. Letters and reports checked and signed under supervision of their clinical supervisor, completing clinical observations and case formulation.
ACP指南中关于可以委派的职责示例（我认为“委派”这个词本身就很重要）包括：根据经验和培训，进行手册化的团体干预、手册化的一对一干预、心理测量评估、在监督下完成和录入数据。这并不意味着有人坐在你身边盯着你，只是意味着它应该在监督下进行审查。半结构化的病史采集评估、文献综述和研究（包括审计和服务评估）、制作和修改经主管批准的资源、团队合作、反思性实践、参与（而非主持）团队会议、建立人脉、同行监督和培训。信件和报告需在临床主管的监督下检查并签署，完成临床观察和案例构思。
APs should not be expected to carry out the duties of a health care assistant, supporting personal care or excessive non-clinical admin tasks. I just thought that was really really interesting yeah definitely um it's i would probably hazard to say that it's not the norm what we've just read across ap roles though many of those things might be included i don't think that list is the norm unfortunately does it you know i know we we've kind of spoke before we started recording that maybe actually that almost feels like old school and that it's not exciting enough to gain you a place valid safe experience I almost said training experience but it's not a training experience it's a developmental experience that supports your own development but also is of benefit to the clients in the service but like I said helps
不应期望助理心理学家（AP）履行医疗助理的职责，如提供个人护理或过多的非临床行政任务。我觉得这非常有趣。我敢说，虽然我们读到的许多内容可能包含在AP角色中，但这在AP角色中并不是常态。不幸的是，我不认为那份清单是常态。我知道我们在录音前聊过，这感觉像是老派的做法，而且不够令人兴奋，无法为你赢得一个有效的、安全的经验。我差点说是培训经验，但这不是培训经验，这是一种支持你自身发展的成长经验，同时也对服务中的客户有益。
I mean what I read just then is is exactly what I understood the role of assistant to be, to allow the optimal functioning of a qualified psychologist by metering out tasks that don't necessarily need to be done by a qualified psychologist. But does it maybe not feel fruity enough? It doesn't feel exciting enough to not be burned out and doing all of the jobs of a qualified psychologist these days. It definitely, to me, doesn't sound normal. And through speaking with others, I've heard of people doing roles that are pretty much that. And that, as you say, technically technically is what assistant psychologists should be doing.
我的意思是，我刚才读到的正是对助理心理学家角色的理解，即通过分担那些不一定需要合格心理学家完成的任务，来使合格心理学家能够实现最佳工作状态。但它是否感觉不够“多汁”？感觉不够令人兴奋，以至于不会感到精疲力竭，而且现在还要做合格心理学家的所有工作。对我来说，这绝对听起来不正常。通过与其他人交谈，我听说有人做的工作确实就是那样。正如你所说，从技术上讲，这确实是助理心理学家应该做的事情。
But when discussing this with other APs or trainees who were APs, as you say, that sounds boring or more boring. And they should be doing much more clinical stuff. They should be doing essentially like a filtered down version of what trainees do. And that, in a sense, discredits what trainees do because there is quite a big difference. And they are, towards the end of their time, obviously expected to be picking up more and more clinical work, more and more important and potentially risky contact with people.
但当与其他AP或曾担任AP的实习生讨论时，正如你所说，这听起来很无聊，或者更无聊。他们应该做更多的临床工作。他们本质上应该做实习生所做工作的简化版。从某种意义上说，这贬低了实习生所做的工作，因为两者之间有很大的区别。而且，在他们任期的后期，显然期望他们承担更多、更重要的临床工作，以及与人接触时潜在的风险。
And I don't know where it's come from, but you being around the profession for a bit longer than me, like maybe you understand where this has stemmed from with regards to why an assistant should be expected either of themselves or people in the department, to be picking up these more, as you say, juicy, fruity sort of parts of what a psychologist will eventually be doing. Because all these things are really, really important to be good at. Psychometrics testing is really good. Research, literature reviews. The clinical admin is, as you said, still a really important part of your job unfortunately
我不知道这种想法从何而来，但你在这一行待的时间比我长，也许你明白为什么助理心理学家会被期望（无论是他们自己还是部门里的人）去承担这些你所说的“多汁的、有趣的”心理学家最终会做的工作。因为所有这些技能都非常重要。心理测量测试非常好。研究、文献综述。正如你所说，临床行政工作不幸地仍然是你工作中非常重要的一部分。
but it will always be a part of the job so i don't know where this has come from and it's it's really refreshing to see it written down in this guideline that it is okay to be doing that you don't have to think that you're missing out that you're you're doing something more boring because it is really important skills you're learning. Exactly. And actually the trainee role. So making that distinction that post-graduation, you are not in a trainee role. This is where it's really relevant because actually when you become a trainee psychologist, you are then needing to learn all of the skills and all the capabilities to work within the KSFs of a qualified practitioner, psychologist. And the same is not true. You know, we are supporting the function as assistant psychologists. And, you know, even placement students, they are below the level of
但这永远是工作的一部分，所以我不知道这种想法从何而来。在指南中看到明确写着“做这些是可以的”真的很令人耳目一新。你不必认为自己错过了什么，或者在做更无聊的事情，因为你正在学习非常重要的技能。确实如此。实际上，实习生的角色——做出这种区分很重要，即毕业后，你不再处于实习生角色。这正是相关之处，因为当你成为实习心理学家时，你需要学习在合格从业者、心理学家的KSF（知识与技能框架）内工作的所有技能和能力。作为助理心理学家，我们是在支持其功能，情况并非如此。即使是实习学生，他们的期望水平也低于合格水平，
expectation because they haven't yet got their psychology graduation. You know, they haven't got that qualification. Whereas I think often placement students are just used as assistant psychologists and honorary assistant psychologists are used as as assistant psychologists as well and it's it's not ethical it's not right and I've remembered my other point was that you know you being a slightly older applicant it's lovely to see in the profession also lovely to see someone who identifies as male because I know predominantly it is still a very female heavy profession so um lovely to see that on on both those but it's it's not very affordable to be an assistant psychologist you know and actually that affects the diversity as well so when i was an assistant i was getting paid 13 000 pounds a year um you know not a lot of money not a lot of money I know it's better now
因为他们还没有获得心理学学位。他们没有那个资格。然而，我认为实习学生经常被当作助理心理学家使用，荣誉助理心理学家也被当作助理心理学家使用，这不道德，也不正确。我记得我的另一点是，作为一个稍微年长的申请者，在这一行看到你很高兴，也很高兴看到有人认同男性身份，因为我知道这仍然是一个女性占主导地位的职业。所以，很高兴看到这两点。但作为助理心理学家并不太负担得起，这实际上也影响了多样性。当我还是助理时，我一年挣13000英镑，钱不多，我知道现在好多了，
you know band four and band five is better now but still the cost of living has increased and so in order to be you know I don't it's not my place to ask about your family in your situation but in order to be in your 30s and an assistant that's's harder. There's probably people that you went to school with who are on double, maybe triple the salary that you're on. And that's really hard. Yeah, there are definitely people who are on double and triple. I myself have been on double the salary before a few years ago in a separate industry and would be on considerably more money now
现在四级和五级工资好多了，但生活成本也增加了。所以，我不是要打听你的家庭情况，但在30多岁时还要做助理，这更难。和你一起上学的人可能拿着双倍甚至三倍的工资。这真的很艰难。是的，确实有人拿着双倍或三倍的工资。几年前，我在另一个行业时，工资也是现在的两倍，如果我留在那里，现在会挣得更多。
if I'd have stayed there. But the money isn't everything everything but it is definitely important and it is getting to the point where the pressure is mounting for how long can i keep doing this because of the financial side effect that myself and many others even in a worse position than myself will be feeling because you do feel like you give so much because you are trying to trying to progress skill-wise for the personal development to get onto that training but also trying to progress so that you can help the service users at the end of the day and your team and grow in that sense of a useful employee a useful team member and so on and so forth but i think for the work that we do and it's the same across pretty much all of the public sector
如果我留在那儿的话。但钱不是一切，但它绝对很重要。现在压力越来越大，因为经济方面的副作用，我还能坚持多久？我自己和许多处境比我更糟的人都会有这种感觉。因为你觉得你付出了很多，因为你试图在技能上进步，为了个人发展以进入培训，但也试图进步以便最终能帮助服务对象、你的团队，并成长为一个有用的员工、有用的团队成员等等。但我认为对于我们所做的工作，在整个公共部门几乎都是一样的，
we we probably are not we're probably not financially rewarded as well as we could be or should be and i'm not talking a huge jump because granted we're not qualified and there should be a big difference between the two or trainees and so on, but it definitely is a pressure. So thanks for pointing that out. And for myself and others in worse positions, I think we just have to try and remember why we are doing it. Hopefully one day we will qualify and we will be able to sort of work with others
我们的经济回报可能没有我们能得到或应该得到的那么好。我不是说要大幅跳涨，因为我们确实没有资格，两者之间应该有很大的区别，或者实习生等等，但这绝对是一种压力。所以谢谢你指出这一点。对于我自己和其他处境更糟的人，我想我们只需要试着记住我们为什么这样做。希望有一天我们能获得资格，并能够在更高的层面上改变服务。
and maybe make these changes in services on a higher level. Absolutely. But I think you're very much ready for the Band 6 training role. I would be incredibly surprised if you don't have interviews in this next year, because I think you are, you know, I'm what I would be looking for. I, if I was on a panel, I'm seeing within you. So I'm wishing you the very best if you do choose to apply next year. I have to say, once I was a trainee, I was actually slightly better off financially than I was as a qualified member of staff because I then lost all of my, um, I had to, there was no jobs
绝对是这样。但我认为你已经完全准备好迎接六级培训职位了。如果你明年没有面试机会，我会感到非常惊讶，因为我认为你就是我所寻找的人。如果我是面试小组成员，我会在你身上看到这些特质。所以，如果你明年选择申请，我祝你一切顺利。我必须说，一旦我成为实习生，我的经济状况实际上比我作为合格员工时稍微好一点，因为那时我失去了所有的……没有工作，
and I had to travel basically an hour each way for work, but that was on my own expense. So I wasn't getting any mileage, um, for my home to base. And then I had to start paying council tax as well. So I I I was worse off as a band seven than I was as a band six so you know it's not always the holy grail that you're like I'm onto the big money now um yes but I would hope that if you I went from band four to band six when I went from assistant to training and I loved it when I first looked at my pay slip for what was like basically a month a month and a half oh I felt like a millionaire it was incredible you know the the difference of jumping two bands and getting paid basically for a month and a half so I hope that you enjoy
我不得不每天往返一小时去上班，但这完全是我自己的开销。所以我没有得到任何从家到基地的里程补贴。然后我还得开始缴纳市政税。所以作为七级员工，我比作为六级员工时更穷。所以，这并不总是你认为的“我现在拿大钱了”的圣杯。是的，但我希望如果你……我从助理转为实习生时，是从四级跳到六级，我第一次看工资单时非常喜欢，那是一个半月的工资，我觉得自己像个百万富翁，太不可思议了。跳两级并获得一个半月的工资，所以我希望你享受
the enhanced salary when it comes but you know people are often starting when they've already got mortgages they've already got children you know they've already got overheads they've already got car payments you know it's not it's not easy are highly skilled, qualified, you know, not professionally qualified, but they've got, they've often got undergraduate, well, they have to have an undergraduate degree. They've often got masters. Some of them have even already got doctorates or PhDs, like it's wild, the amount of skills and expertise. Now I'm really sorry, because I'm very much enjoying chatting with you. But I am, as I say, in the podcast, I am still a practicing clinician. And I have got a client in 15 minutes, and we need to give some good time for this episode to upload. And so I am going to have to cut us a little bit shorter. but I have loved speaking with you.
当你拿到更高的工资时。但人们开始时往往已经有了抵押贷款、孩子、日常开销、车贷，这并不容易。他们技术娴熟、有资格（虽然不是专业资格），但他们通常有本科学位，他们必须有本科学位。他们通常有硕士学位。有些人甚至已经有了博士学位，这太疯狂了，他们的技能和专业知识水平。现在我很抱歉，因为我很享受和你聊天。但正如我在播客中所说，我仍然是一名执业临床医生。我15分钟后有一个客户，我们需要给这一集留出足够的时间上传。所以我不得不缩短我们的谈话，但我很喜欢和你交谈。
I, yeah, I'm excited for good things to come your way. Have you got any advice for reducing burnout in this profession of ours? Yeah, it's probably quite cliche, but personally, it's to me, it's exercise of some form or another. That's the top for me. It doesn't have to be intense. It can be just walking through nature and so on and so forth, especially in this beautiful weather. That would be the start. But then I would say to people, find your hobbies and lean into those hobbies, whether it's reading, writing, sports, walking the dog, whatever you want, you can tailor that.
我为你即将到来的好事感到兴奋。你对减轻我们这一行的职业倦怠有什么建议吗？是的，这可能很陈词滥调，但对我个人而言，是某种形式的锻炼。这是我的首选。它不必很剧烈。它可以只是在自然中行走等等，特别是在这美好的天气里。那是开始。但我会告诉人们，找到你的爱好并投入其中，无论是阅读、写作、运动、遛狗，无论你想要什么，你都可以定制它。
Because I think the stress really goes up, commitments go up. Those parts of you are kind of what help keep your identity in the middle, which is really to keep yourself grounded and not lose yourself to work. So that's what I like. I try and a lot of things which can be counterproductive sometimes but I do try and keep myself very busy good well done well done to you and we haven't really had time to do justice to so much of this stuff and I wanted to kind of mention the the workload of PWPs which is sometimes like 60 70 80 percent face-to-face time and it's like whoa whoa whoa but sometimes assistants are doing similar stuff but that is probably a conversation for another day thank you so much for your time
因为我认为压力确实会增加，承诺也会增加。这些部分是你保持自我认同的核心，这对于保持脚踏实地、不迷失在工作中非常重要。所以我喜欢这样。我尝试做很多事情，有时可能会适得其反，但我确实尽量让自己保持忙碌。很好，做得好。我们没有时间充分讨论这些内容，我想提一下PWP（心理健康从业者）的工作量，有时是60%、70%、80%的面对面时间，这太惊人了。但有时助理也在做类似的事情，但这可能是改天再聊的话题。非常感谢你的时间，
luke thank you for having me on i appreciate it and um i'll be keeping up to date and i don't know maybe maybe in the future we can have another chat that would be wonderful wishing you well thank you thanks marianne thank you what an amazing chat with luke how lucky are we to have had him join us for this episode i am hopeful for good things to come for luke after this episode was in the can i contacted luke to say that i'd seen some bpa and that maybe it would be a good idea for us to read it and to come up with a part two of this episode and so that is what is coming this is now going to be an assistant psychologist season and you can catch the next episode which will be coming along next week there is no need to listen or watch in order though.
Luke，谢谢你邀请我，我很感激。我会保持关注，也许未来我们可以再聊一次，那会很棒。祝你一切顺利，谢谢。谢谢Marianne，谢谢。与Luke的谈话真是太棒了，我们能邀请他参加这一集真是太幸运了。我希望Luke在这一集之后会有好事发生。在这一集录制完成后，我联系了Luke，说我看到了一些BPA（英国心理学会）的内容，也许我们读一下并制作这一集的第二部分会是个好主意。所以这就是即将发生的事情。这现在将成为一个助理心理学家系列，你可以在下周收听下一集。不过，不需要按顺序收听或观看。
So whichever order you've stumbled across these, please do dive in. If you have loved these chats, I think you probably would love the chats that I have with people and the support that is offered and the great sense of community in the Aspiring Psychologist membership,
所以无论你从哪个顺序偶然发现这些内容，请尽情深入了解。如果你喜欢这些谈话，我想你可能会喜欢我和人们进行的谈话，以及在“有抱负的心理学家会员”中提供的支持和伟大的社区感，
which you can join for just 30 pounds a month with no minimum term it gets really wonderful reviews and we are getting astounding results i think you'll also really like the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book too do come and connect with me on socials where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and come and join the free Facebook group which is the unique and very special only home for Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions which happen once a week in that group absolutely for free and that is over on Facebook. If you do value this podcast a way that you can help me and any podcaster that you appreciate for free is simply by subscribing, by liking, by interacting with their content.
你只需每月支付30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。它获得了非常好的评价，我们正在取得惊人的成果。我想你也会非常喜欢《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书和《临床心理学家集体》这本书。欢迎在社交媒体上与我联系，我是Marianne Trent博士，并加入免费的Facebook群组，这是Marianne的动力和心态课程的唯一家园，每周在群组中免费进行一次。如果你重视这个播客，你可以免费帮助我以及任何你欣赏的播客作者，只需订阅、点赞、与他们的内容互动即可。
It absolutely means the world. Thank you for being part of my world and I will look forward to bringing you the next episode of the podcast, which will be released on youtube dr marianne trent from 10 a.m on saturday and wherever you get your podcast 6 a.m on monday With this podcast that you'll see, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and
这对我来说意义重大。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待着为你带来下一集播客，它将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并在周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方发布。通过这个播客，你会走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，
there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。